aux portes de l'ukraine alors que ces
forces russes jusque-là déployés près de
la frontière retournent dans leurs
garnisons le chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne se félicite ce mardi d'avoir
évité une nouvelle escalade russe kiev
indique que la situation reste tendue
mais sous contrôle et le kremlin
confirme le début d'un retrait militaire
planifiée
pas le même son de cloche du côté de
washington dans une interview exclusive
accordée à france 24 quelques heures
auparavant ce secrétaire d'état
américain anthony blinken rester prudent
une agression dès cette semaine est tout
à fait possible quand on voit ce qui se
passe autour de l'ukraine avec le
déploiement des forces russes on retient
toute hypothèse pour avancer la
diplomatie mais dans un premier temps ça
dépend entièrement de la russie et la
russie qui a déjà annexé la crimée en
2014 affirme depuis plusieurs semaines
qu'elle n'a aucune intention d'envahir
l'ukraine et d'y croire encore à la
diplomatie
nous mettons en garde contre des
conversations interminables sur la
résolution de problèmes qui doivent être
résolus aujourd'hui mais néanmoins en
tant que ministre des affaires
étrangères je dois dire qu'il ya
toujours une chance
mais moscou exige que kiev renonce à
adhérer à l'otan une condition
inacceptable pour les occidentaux
poutine veut empêcher l'ukraine d'avoir
sa souveraineté son intégrité ne veut à
sa porte qu'un soft santé dire qu'on est
à croupion la demo poutine ne veut pas
de pays qui soit à même de choisir ses
choix de l'alliance
et l'allemagne comme la france tente
également de peser dans les discussions
après une rencontre en ukraine avec le
président et lens qui le chancelier
allemand olaf scholz rencontre vladimir
poutine à moscou ce mardi